In the last video, I introduced
you to what is
probably the most bizarro
function that you've
encountered so far.
And that was the Dirac
delta function.
And I defined it to be--
and I'll do the
shifted version of it.
You're already hopefully
reasonably familiar with it.
So Dirac delta of t minus c.
We can say that it equals 0,
when t does not equal c, so it
equals 0 everywhere, but it
essentially pops up to infinity.
And we have to be careful
with this infinity.
I'm going to write
it in quotes.
It pops up to infinity.
And we even saw in the previous
video, it's kind of
different degrees of infinity,
because you can still multiply
this by other numbers to get
larger Dirac delta functions
when t is equal to c.
But more important than this,
and this is kind of a
pseudodefinition here, is the
idea that when we take the
integral, when we take the area
under the curve over the
entire x- or the entire t-axis,
I guess we could say,
when we take the area under this
curve, and obviously, it
equals zero everywhere except
at t is equal to c, when we
take this area, this is the
important point, that the area
is equal to 1.
And so this is what I meant by
pseudoinfinity, because if I
have 2 times the Dirac delta
function, and if I'm taking
the area under the curve of
that, of 2 times the Dirac
delta function t minus c dt,
this should be equal to 2
times-- the area of just under
the Dirac delta function 2
times from minus infinity to
infinity of the delta function
shifted by c dt, which is just
2 times-- we already showed
you, I just said, by definition,
this is 1, so this
will be equal to 2.
So if I put a 2 out here, this
infinity will have to be twice
as high, so that the
area is now 2.
That's why I put that infinity
in parentheses.
But it's an interesting
function.
I talked about it at the end of
the last video that it can
help model things that kind of
jar things all of a sudden,
but they impart a fixed amount
of impulse on something and a
fixed amount of change
in momentum.
And we'll understand that a
little bit more in the future.
But let's kind of get the
mathematical tools completely
understood.
And let's try to figure out what
the Dirac delta function
does when we multiply it, what
it does to the Laplace
transform when we multiply
it times some function.
So let's say I have my Dirac
delta function and I'm going
to shift it.
That's a little bit
more interesting.
And if you want to unshift
it, you just say, OK,
well, c equals 0.
What happens when c equals 0?
And I'm going to shift it and
multiply it times some
arbitrary function f of t.
If I wanted to figure out the
Laplace transform of just the
delta function by itself,
I could say f of
t is equal to 1.
So let's take our Laplace
transform of this.
And we can just use the
definition of the Laplace
transform, so this is equal to
the area from 0 to infinity,
or we could call it the integral
from 0 to infinity of
e to the minus -- that's just
part of the Laplace transform
definition-- times this thing--
and I'll just write it
in this order-- times
f of t times
our Dirac delta function.
Delta t minus c and times dt.
Now, here I'm going to
make a little bit of
an intuitive argument.
A lot of the math we do is kind
of-- especially if you
want to be very rigorous and
formal, the Dirac delta
function starts to break down a
lot of tools that you might
have not realized it would
break down, but I think
intuitively, we can still
work with it.
So I'm going to solve this
integral for you intuitively,
and I think it'll
make some sense.
So let's draw this.
Let me draw this, what
we're trying to do.
So let me draw what we're
trying to take
the integral of.
And we only care from zero to
infinity, so I'll only do it
from zero to infinity.
And I'll assume that c is
greater than zero, that the
delta function pops
up someplace in
the positive t-axis.
So what is this first part
going to look like?
What is that going to look
like? e to the minus
st times f of t?
I don't know.
It's going to be some function.
e to the minus st
starts at 1 and drops down, but
we're multiplying it times
some arbitrary function, so I'll
just draw it like this.
Maybe it looks something
like this.
This right here is e to the
minus st times f of t.
And the f of t is what kind of
gives it its arbitrary shape.
Fair enough.
Now, let's graph our Dirac
delta function.
With zero everywhere except
right at c, right at c right
there, it pops up infinitely
high, but we only draw an
arrow that is of height 1 to
show that its area is 1.
I mean, normally when you graph
things you don't draw
arrows, but this arrow shows
that the area under this
infinitely high thing is 1.
So we do a 1 there.
So if we multiply this, we care
about the area under this
whole thing.
When we multiply these two
functions, when we multiply
this times this times the delta
function, this is-- let
me write this.
This is the delta function
shifted to c.
If I multiply that times
that, what do I get?
This is kind of the key
intuition here.
Let me redraw my axes.
Let me see if I can do it
a little bit straighter.
Don't judge me by the
straightness of my axes.
So that's t.
So what happens when I
multiply these two?
Everywhere, when t equals
anything other than c, the
Dirac delta function is zero.
So it's zero times anything.
I don't care what this function
is going to do, it's
going to be zero.
So it's going to be zero
everywhere, except something
interesting happens at
t is equal to c.
At t equals c, what's the
value of the function?
Well, it's going to
be the value of
the Dirac delta function.
It's going to be the Dirac delta
function times whatever
height this is.
This is going to be this point
right here or this right
there, that point.
This is going to be this
function evaluated at c.
I'll mark it right here on the
y-axis, or on the f of t,
whatever you want to call it.
This is going to be e to the
minus sc times f of c.
All I'm doing is I'm just
evaluating this function at c,
so that's the point
right there.
So if you take this point, which
is just some number, it
could be 5, 5 times this, you're
just getting 5 times
the Dirac delta function.
Or in this case, it's not 5.
It's this little more
abstract thing.
I could just draw
it like this.
When I multiply this thing times
my little delta function
there, I get this.
The height, it's a delta
function, but it's scaled now.
It's scaled, so now my
new thing is going
to look like this.
If I just multiply that times
that, I essentially get e to
the minus sc times f of c.
This might look like some fancy
function, but it's just
a number when we consider
it in terms of t.
s, it becomes something when we
go into the Laplace world,
but from t's point of view,
it's just a constant.
All of these are just constants,
so this might as
well just be 5.
So it's this constant times my
Dirac delta function, times
delta of t minus c.
When I multiply that thing times
that thing, all I'm left
with is this thing.
And this height is still going
to be infinitely high, but
it's infinitely high scaled in
such a way that its area is
going to be not 1.
And I'll show it to you.
So what's the integral
of this thing?
Taking the integral of this
thing from minus infinity to
infinity, since this thing is
this thing, it should be the
same thing as taking the
integral of this thing from
minus infinity to infinity.
So let's do that.
Actually, we don't have to do
it from minus infinity.
I said from zero to infinity.
So if we take from zero to
infinity, what I'm saying is
taking this integral
is equivalent
to taking this integral.
So e to the minus sc f of c
times my delta function t
minus c dt.
Now, this thing right here, let
me make this very clear,
I'm claiming that this is
equivalent to this.
Because everywhere else, the
delta function zeroes out this
function, so we only care about
this function, or e to
the minus st f of t when
t is equal to c.
And so that's why we were able
to turn it into a constant.
But since this is a constant,
we can bring it out of the
integral, and so this is equal
to-- I'm going to go backwards
here just to kind of save space
and still give you these
things to look at.
If we take out the constants
from inside of the integral,
we get e to the minus sc times f
of c times the integral from
0 to infinity of f
of t minus c dt.
Oh sorry, not f of t minus c.
This is not an f.
I have to be very careful.
This is a delta.
Let me do that in a
different color.
I took out the constant terms
there, and it's going to be a
delta of t minus c dt.
Let me get the right color.
Now, what is this thing
by definition?
This thing is 1.
I mean, we could put it from
minus infinity to infinity, it
doesn't matter.
The only time where it has any
area is right under c.
So this thing is equal to 1.
So this whole integral right
there has been reduced to this
right there, because this
is just equal to 1.
So the Laplace transform of
our shifted delta function
times some other function is
equal to e to the minus sc
times f of c.
Let me write that
again down here.
Let me write it all at once.
So the Laplace transform of our
shifted delta function t
minus c times some function
f of t, it equals e
to the minus c.
Essentially, we're just
evaluating e to the minus st
evaluated at c.
So e to the minus
cs times f of c.
We're essentially just
evaluating these things at c.
This is what it equals.
So from this we can get a lot
of interesting things.
What is the Laplace transform--
actually, what is
the Laplace transform
of just the plain
vanilla delta function?
Well, in this case, we have c
is equal to 0, and f of t is
equal to 1.
It's just a constant term.
So if we do that, then the
Laplace transform of this
thing is just going to be e to
the minus 0 times s times 1,
which is just equal to 1.
So the Laplace transform of our
delta function is 1, which
is a nice clean thing
to find out.
And then if we wanted to just
figure out the Laplace
transform of our shifted
function, the Laplace
transform of our shifted delta
function, this is just a
special case where f
of t is equal to 1.
We could write it times 1, where
f of t is equal to 1.
So this is going to be equal to
e to the minus cs times f
of c, but f is just a constant,
f is just 1 here.
So it's times 1, or it's
just e to the mine cs.
So just like that, using a kind
of visual evaluation of
the integral, we were able
to figure out the Laplace
transforms for a bunch of
different situations involving
the Dirac delta function.
Anyway, hopefully, you found
that reasonably useful.